i'm samantha harris
these five cooks are about to be thrown
into a furious
contest that will test their culinary
limits they've each brought something
from their kitchen at home to help them
today and later
gordon ramsay will be giving them tips
now casting his eye over the proceedings
is
a legend in the kitchen chef edward lee
how you doing my sweet chef what do you
have lined up for these fine folks today
so we have a simple challenge to test
their culinary knowledge
the three cooks who perform the best
will move on to the cook-off
where they will have a pantry full of
french
italian and indian ingredients thank you
very much edward
so let's reveal what's in store for
round one
contestants please lift your cloches
[Music]
it's an herb garden in front of you are
eight labeled jars
and an herb garden you must put the
correct herbs into the corresponding
jars
the three cooks who get the most answers
correct will go through to round two
contestants you have five minutes let
the battle
begin
[Music]
edward what is your favorite herb to
cook with i love every herb under the
sun
it just makes your cooking so bright but
if i had to choose one it would be
cilantro
i can put it in almost anything really
so versatile i love it
let's check out how they're doing
[Music]
hello there dominique all right do you
cook with herbs a lot
parsley meals just parsley just
garnishes on your dishes at restaurants
uh-oh
go through the ones i know and then you
know try to do the rest
michelle are you having trouble with
this is this good is something that
you've
done before i've never done this before
no i like what you're doing though
you're smelling them
so that that's a good technique i know
that you like to cook healthfully so you
probably use a lot of
produce i do so then do you cook with
herbs a lot as well for flavors mostly
dry herbs though oh that's
a lot different it is a lot different um
but my family has always been growing
fresh
in the garden things like that so i'm
familiar with a few things but there
seems to be a lot of
sort of exotic more things that i don't
normally use so i'm kind of playing a
bit of a guessing game
look at you you're like mowing a lawn
you're supposed to be clipping herbs
keep it neat if you get more than one
herb in the same jar
that disqualifies it so make sure it's
just one herb per jar thank you
i know you brought a garlic press from
home today so clearly you like cooking
with garlic i love cooking with garlic
also with herbs
yes especially things like oregano and
basil
any that you're struggling with yet well
sometimes it's a bit confusing between
you know a couple of the different types
but i've got my fingers crossed
doing all right she's pretty confident
with that scissor and getting them in
the right jars
bernani's got a mess of herbs on his
table i want to make sure that he gets
them all in the right jars not kind of
all mixed up together dominic seems a
little bit unsure of herself i don't
think she's as familiar with all these
herbs
justin likes to cook healthfully but
tends to use dry herbs
dry and fresh are totally different is
it always better to use fresh herbs most
of the time
got to be careful though if you use
dried herbs it's much more intense than
the fresh variety so you have to use
less of it so in what sort of instances
would we use dried herbs instead
if you're doing something where you want
to rub a piece of meat
and sear it on a pan you wouldn't want
to use fresh i've got them mixed
up ten nine
eight seven six five
four three two one
so now it is time for edward to judge
our contestants and explain
how to tell your tarragon from your time
all right
ciao let's see how you did okay let's
start with parsley parsley is
probably the most common of herbs very
grassy very
vibrant let's come around here you put
cilantro in there
they kind of look similar cilantro has a
lot more
curly frilly leaves on the outside and
if you smell them very different
cilantro's very aromatic very soapy
almost
next one you did get right which is dill
it's got that
little frilly lines that come out it's
very distinctive
and the smell it's very fresh fragrant
herb thai basil so you
almost got it right this is italian
basil
not thai basil thai basil looks like
this similar smell but very different
thai basil has a much more pronounced
aniseed flavor almost like licorice
italian basil you would very lightly
chop them and use them
in pastas with thai basil you can use
them in stronger stews goes great with
coconut milk goes great with spices
next oregano what you picked was
thyme thyme is distinctive because of
the tiny little leaves
and the long stems very minty peppery
almost
lemony oregano almost medicinal a little
bit bitter
where's my sage here we go sage long
leaves they almost look like cat ears
and then feel them
feel like they have a fur on top of it
it's very strong you
rarely will see it too much in its raw
form a lot of it's dry
a lot of it's cooked so this is your
time what i love about thyme is that
it's really versatile
what you thought was thyme was actually
tarragon
and what you thought was tarragon was
thai basil
so tarragon is very delicate leaves
you can't cook it over high heat too
much you'll find this a lot in french
cooking
and last but not least you have marjoram
actually very close to oregano and
that's the two get
confused the most often marjoram has
slightly more delicate leaves whereas
oregano leaves are a little bit more
wrinkled
and the flavor is similar but a little
bit more grassy
you have two out of eight
well ernani you saw what happened there
with chell now we'll see when chef takes
you through yours how you doing
all right today you only got one right
you know which one it is
dill yeah deal everything else is wrong
so you were tempted of at first right
you weren't very sure of yourself these
are the only two
that you got wrong
wow you got six out of eight
congratulations
so flip-flopped you only got two right
right a deal in the time
um but everyone's not doing so well so
you still got hope
we'll see how do you think you did i'm
quietly confident because quite a few of
these i have in my garden all right well
i love you know why because you got
seven out of eight
so you were so close to a perfect score
the only one you got wrong is the
oregano so that means the contestants
going through to the final are
with a score of seven out of eight wendy
and as justin and chell both got a score
of two out of eight they must play a
tiebreak challenge
high break i know well sally of course
though that does mean that with a score
of one out of eight or nani
you're going home but thank you so much
for joining us today
welcome back for this tie break
challenge
you must extract as much juice as
possible from the lemons provided
in 30 seconds the person with the most
juice in their tube at the end
will go through to round two all right
you guys got it yeah you're ready
yes let's go squeeze squeeze
[Music]
that's right start squeezing guys get
your water in there
[Applause]
seven six six five
four three two one stop doing there
you put your arms and your effort into
it let's get those test tubes
carefully pour it if it spills on the
side we can't count it
wow holy moly
okay justin you pulled off 176
milliliters of lemon juice in there
we're gonna see if chow can do better
[Music]
all right justin you got the most so you
are through to round two congratulations
and of course unfortunately we have to
say goodbye to you right here but thank
you so much for participating today
opportunity
now just three cooks remain in
contention for the title of culinary
genius now to win our finalists will
have to really impress
edward with a fantastic dish but first
here's
chef extraordinaire gordon ramsay to
reveal the protein they'll need to cook
with in this round
right today we'll be cooking with this
incredible delicious turkey
now americans eat 200 million of these
birds every year
but what would i do with it you know
it's not just about the breast the
flavor in that dark meat is incredible
so i'd butter baste it and roast the
whole thing and serve it with the most
amazing roasted vegetables
but my first experience in america
thanksgiving
my friend deep fat friday promise me
you'll never deep fat fry this gorgeous
bird
it's healthy and it's lean and it needs
to stay at the fryer
guys good luck so edward what are you
looking for from
our three finalists today i want a
beautiful elevated
flavorful turkey dish from you now you
must use
at least one herb so think about what
you're gonna do
and deliver me one beautiful dish well
to make that
winning dish of course you're gonna need
some ingredients from our pantry but you
have
just two minutes to select them your
time for the pantry
starts now
edward what's in the pantry today so
there's puff pastry there's endive
there's wild mushrooms fennel dried
cranberries
cornbread and burger buns
justin's picking everything in sight i
just wanted to grab as much as i
possibly could to give myself the most
options when i actually got to cooking
ten nine eight
[Music]
you have 25 minutes to cook like you've
never
cooked before so let the battle
[Applause]
what else did you grab from the pantry
beside those potatoes um i grabbed some
apples some bacon
the cornbread cranberries mushrooms big
piece of cabbage
i'm just gonna toggle some potatoes and
then pan fry them
and then i'm gonna pan fry the turkey
breast make a
cranberry cornbread crumb and then also
do
um the buttered mushrooms what's a
british
person like you know about cornbread
cranberry oh
well i just switched i thought
thanksgiving and i said that's what i
would have done
so what is this you brought um that's a
stock cube so i use it to season
anything i cook with basically it's
basically better than salt
tell me everything that you grabbed from
the pantry from the pantry we just have
some
potatoes and some greens we're gonna go
for a turkey burger
um but a little bit of a thanksgiving
twist oh so i'm gonna have some
cranberry on there as well deep fried
onion rings aside
what herb are you using i think i'm
gonna just use some thyme with the onion
rings
turkey burger is a great idea but it's a
very simple dish
this is an elevated competition we're
talking culinary genius
it's got to be the best turkey burger
i've ever had
well hi there wendy already it fast it
used to be that garlic press yes
here's what i don't like about a garlic
press it really juices the garlic
what i like to do is take the garlic
smack it with a knife and then chop it
real fast yeah and you know what happens
it actually
preserves the flavor inside the garlic
versus getting it all on the cutting
board
what else did you grab from the pantry
well i've got some bacon i'm going to do
is a
turkey cacciatore tell me what a
kachitori is explain
it's a nice kind of italian sauce with
tomato puree and white wine and it's a
family favorite
i have made a variation of this dish
before but
only with chicken so it's it's a new
kind of departure for me and i'm hoping
that it tastes as good now as it does at
home
i'm going to pound the turkey breast
down to make it more like an escalope
and then
sauce on top so fingers crossed 25
minutes you got it i know
what herb are you using i'm using basil
and flat parsley
and a bit of oregano
dominic is making a pan fried turkey
with a cranberry
cornbread crumble what so britt know
about thanksgiving i mean does she
really know how to incorporate those
flavors together yeah i hope she can
pull it off
justin is making a thanksgiving inspired
turkey burger
i've had some really good turkey burgers
so now if it's not the best turkey
burger i've ever had
i might take off some points for that
wendy is making a
turkey cacciatore it's a classic recipe
it's gonna work well with the turkey she
might have to add a little bit of
fat to it right because turkey's a
pretty lean cut of meat so
you run the risk of having pretty bland
flavorless textureless meat
15 minutes remaining i want the cooks to
become
better right i don't want them cooking
something that they think will impress
me i want them to cook something that
will impress them
today's three finalists are locking
heads over turkey as they attempt to
impress
edward and become today's culinary
genius and i want to know how they're
doing
so i'm gonna go find out so justin tell
me who you usually tend to cook for
typically i cook for myself and my
roommate that i'm currently living with
i'm a bit worried that this turkey's not
gonna cook quick
with a thousand dollar cash prize what
would you use it for
um to be honest i probably put it
towards my student loan so i think i've
used that money to sort of pay off
everything i've done to come this far
okay dominique uh who's with you here
today i have my brother here but your
brother's here do you cook for your
brother yeah yeah i cooked family yeah
what do you make for him
anything i'm trying out he's the one
that would give me criticism and
you know uh criticism all right so if
you critique dominique a lot
give her a critique right now how's she
doing i think so far so good i think
maybe just
to relax a little bit hearing from my
brother was great because i was getting
quite um
flustered and so to him tell me to calm
down really helped
what would it mean to be named culinary
genius everything because it really does
prove that i do know how to cook and
it's not just
my family saying it's nice good
hey there wendy you're a mom you're used
to cooking for your family
yeah what do you love cooking for them i
like to do things that are from my heart
that are cooked with love i know what my
family my friends like
and everybody always wants seconds
justin where's your burger it's coming
up okay where's your test burger
my test burn yeah you didn't make a test
burger i didn't make a test person how
are you gonna know if it's done
whenever you make a burger you always
make a second one that's your test
broker to taste and that's how you know
that one's done because you can't bite
into that one right that's true when you
asked me for the test burger
i was freaking out on the inside because
i knew i've done it all wrong but i
decided to roll with it
don't crack that open that's when you
present it to me i don't want a half a
cracked burger
elevate it for me okay right three
minutes everyone here's this all going
on there
yeah this and this and this what's this
um that's the crunch i'm just trying to
adjust
okay taste everything before it goes on
the plate all right
leave enough time for presentation
beautiful plates
wendy yes chef here's what i want to see
from you i want you to elevate it so
it's something that that i might see at
a restaurant
dominique has got a lot on her station i
want to make sure it gets on the plate
and it's not all sitting around on the
cutting board
justin's i don't know because he didn't
make a test burger so we're just gonna
wait and see we're running out of time
ten nine eight seven
six five four three
two one time
you all right all right
welcome back to the final part of
culinary genius where it is time for
edward to judge what our cooks have
created
i think i've come up with a new
variation on thanksgiving i'm really
happy with the presentation i know that
was something that
chef lee wanted us to focus on
aesthetically it looks great so it is
something i would expect to see in a
restaurant it might not be the best
burger in the world but
it's a little bit difficult to elevate
it because it's pretty much
home cooking but hopefully the little
garnishes i've added to it will
do it justice what's the herb that you
used
i use thyme okay i like how all the
components are separated you get the
mushrooms here bacon here potatoes
it's kind of how we would present it at
a restaurant so am i supposed to dump
the sauce over yeah
very smart that way you don't get your
breadcrumbs
wet all right
i did not know if a brit could cook
thanksgiving but i want to come to your
house next thanksgiving
if you'll invite me um
it's very nice the turkey is moist you
know i would have liked maybe a slightly
more elegant presentation
than this big old hunk of turkey right
here potatoes could have been crispier
but listen those are minor points this
is an excellent dish thank you
thank you did you make this cranberry
sauce no
no i just grabbed it from the pan and
did you have bacon
i had bacon unfortunately i did not make
it onto the burger
if you're using uh herbs like this try
and take them off the stem
look how easy it is look at that okay
um
okay a little bit on the dry side this
is why you
always cook a tester burger when you
open up that little one
and you see it's just perfectly moist
you take that one off the pan
your onion rings are perfect nice and
crispy had you had the bacon on there
that sweetness with the fat and then the
turkey would have been like a perfect
punch but overall listen it's a good
turkey burger thank you
i don't have to ask what herbs you're
using because you got a lot of them on
the plate this is basil obviously you
made an effort it's artfully done
we're gonna go in and do a taste
all right i have make hash story before
it takes me an hour to make
i taste all the components on this dish
and it's fabulous but i taste that it's
a 25-minute cacciatore yeah and the
turkey could have used a little bit more
to just kind of sort of melt away into
there
but nice addition with the bacon nice
dish
thank you you have cooked your hearts
out and should be very
very proud but of course there could
only be one
winner
to reveal today's winner finalists
please lift your closures
today's culinary genius is
dominic congratulations
wow i don't know where this dish came
from
but it was genius
you